Yes, this new AI has listened to more than
5,000 songs, and what did it learn? Well,
it learned to perform text to music similarly to
Google’s MusicLM. But this technique is
truly something else. This is MusicGen,
an AI where we enter the kind of music we
wish to hear, and it just gives it to us.
Like this.
Wow. Yes, all this was generated
by an AI. This was a pop dance
track with catchy melodies, tropical percussion,
and upbeat rhythms with the new MusicGen.
And now let’s compare it to Google’s MusicLM.
This one is real good too, and it was
published in this year’s January. However,
the first one you’ve heard, MusicGen
has something up the sleeve. It is an
open source technique that
is free for everyone. Wow.
Now, smooth jazz, with a saxophone solo, piano
chords, and snare drums. First with MusicGen.
That was real good, with a bit of a
saxophone solo. Perhaps a snippet. Now,
the previous work, MusicLM.
I have to say that I really liked the smooth
jazz part better here, that was real good,
however, no saxophone. It is one thing to do well,
but it is not enough - it also
has to follow the prompt as well.
Now, wait a minute. These samples are 30-seconds
long, but real songs are typically much longer
than that. So is that it? No real songs for us?
Well, don’t despair because this paper has two
more absolutely incredible features. One, long
music generation. Oh yes, these are two-minute
long samples, but we are experienced Fellow
Scholars here, so we are looking for long-term
coherence. That means that we will look at
snippets of different parts of the song,
and listen if they really sound like they belong
to the same song. Note that the previous MusicLM
was not as good in this task. Here is the
snippet we looked at in a previous episode.
Now, let’s see if the new MusicGen is any
better on this. I can’t wait - let’s do it!
Wow. First one is flying colors. Not
even a little bit of a drift. Second one.
Maybe you noticed that I liked this one
so much that I was a little reluctant
to skip forward because I wanted to
just keep listening. Coherence was
not as tight as with the previous
one, art and music is subjective,
but if we have a song that has a little more
variation, this is a good one too. Loving it.
And third. This absolutely knocked it out
of the park. Absolutely the same song for
two minutes. This is super difficult to pull
off, and in my opinion, the previous MusicLM
was not as good as this new technique. So much
improvement in just a few months! Incredible.
But we haven’t looked at my absolute favorite
feature yet, I am pretty sure it will be yours
too. They call this feature conditioning, this
essentially can take an already existing piece
of music and remix it with a text prompt.
Listen to the input. And the output.
Wow, this is insanity.
However, not even this work is perfect,
here is something that you might
call somewhat of a failure case.
Yes, the input was maybe recognizable,
but it was jumbled up and not
nearly as good as the other samples.
But wait, here comes the best part.
All this is available to all of you,
free of charge. The source code of this paper is
available, and as of the making of this video,
you can even run it on the web, I’ve put
a link to it in the video description. So,
in the future, we will all have our own
AIs that create a nearly infinite amount
of music personalized to you in real
time. And just imagine what we will
be able to do just a couple more papers
down the line. What a time to be alive!